fox's bill malugion has been on the
story virtually alone since the very
beginning he joins us tonight from the
border at spotford texas with some
remarkable new footage hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you that's
right we're currently about 40 miles
inland from the border right now and
believe it or not this area has turned
into one of the biggest hot spots that's
because all the trains out here the
illegal immigrants have been using them
in an effort to get further into the
united states we'll show you what we're
talking about take a look at this wild
footage shot right here yesterday by
texas dps what you're looking at are
texas state troopers finding 19 illegal
immigrants hiding inside of brand new
cars that were inside of a train being
shipped to the san antonio area you can
see the troopers looking at those
migrants panning up and down and it goes
to show those migrants will do whatever
they can to hide to evade from law
enforcement take a look at this second
piece of video we embedded with dps
earlier today this is what we saw today
we came across one train that had more
than 20 illegal immigrants who were
hiding inside of a coal car believe it
or not in the blistering heat out here
they were all single adult men dps had
to get up there and pull them out one by
one there were 23 in total all of them
were arrested and taken to jail for
criminal trespassing they are not being
handed over to the federal government
take a look at this third piece of video
this was just a couple of hours before
that incident we saw more illegal
immigrants hitching rides on trains out
here texas dps pulled five other single
adult males off of this train arrested
them as well they are all going to jail
as well again they are not being handed
over to border patrol as all of this is
happening there is a brand new migrant
caravan down in mexico heading our way
as we speak take a look at what happened
when they encountered a roadblock from
the mexican government the other day
take a look
[Music]
like a hot knife through butter you can
see they pushed right through that
resistance from the mexican government
and take a look at this video we just
shot here about an hour ago in del rio
went up on a dps helicopter what you're
looking at is the state of texas is now
preparing for this migrant caravan
governor greg abbott is deploying
massive amounts of texas national guard
resources down to the del rio
international bridge area this is the
exact same area where we saw those 15
000 haitians last month the idea behind
this being the state of texas will step
up where the federal government is not
securing the border they say they will
not allow another del rio situation to
happen so they are pre-positioning
resources all along the border there to
send the message to those caravans you
will not be allowed into texas texas dps
telling us unlike the federal government
they will not roll out the red carpet
for these caravans we'll send it back to
you
man that's heartening to hear bill
molition thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else